as we do ac analysis and we do
operations in the in the frequency
domain we need to bring along
kirchhoff's laws so that we can we can
make sense of circuits so in this video
i'm going to basically show that
kirchhoff's voltage law
works in the frequency domain
what i have here is a circuit that has
some voltage source an ac voltage source
let's put ac on it like that
and it has three impedances connected
inside each of these boxes is an r and l
or a c
and i we're not going to show which
because we're going to carry these along
just as general impedances
so in ac analysis
the voltages are all cosine waves so v
in
equals uh some voltage amplitude times
cos
of
omega t
plus we'll call it we'll call it phi
zero
some starting phase shift so this is our
input signal now let me label the
voltages on everything else we'll call
this v1
and we'll i'm going to label it this way
here
and this will be v2
and i'll put it upside down like that
plus and this will be v3
minus
plus
v3
and oh now that i have v1 here let's
let's change the name of this to v0 just
so i don't get i and one mixed up so
we'll change that to zero so the input
source is v zero
and that's that voltage
now when we apply kvl to this
kirchhoff's voltage law
what it says is if we start in a corner
if we start somewhere in the circuit
let's start right here
and go around the loop it should add up
to
0 volts that's kvl for normal dc
circuits and we're going to see how that
applies to ac circuits here
so in time domain we say that v zero
plus v one
plus v two
plus v three
equals zero
so let's talk about how this is going to
turn out what do we know right now well
we know that v0
is a cosine wave at some some phase
angle now what do we know about
the other voltages in this
in ac analysis what we're doing is we're
looking for a forced response so we've
let the natural responses to die out
there's no switch in this circuit and we
just assume this circuit has been in
this state forever
so the natural response
the natural response has died out
and that means we're looking for the
forced response
so what we know is we have three
voltages we have three voltages
we know
that all these voltages are going to
resemble
the input voltage so they're all going
to be
sinusoids
all the voltages here are going to be ac
sinusoids because the forcing function
is a sinusoid
the other thing we know
they're going to all have the same
omega
the frequency of this voltage and this
voltage in this voltage is going to be
identical to omega here i'm going to put
a big
bang there
that's really important in an ac circuit
when you're driving it from a frequency
every other frequency in the system is
the same frequency
this is a linear system and linear
components if we all the analysis we've
done
linear components don't create new
frequencies they're all omega
now some other things we know
there's going to be phase shifts
involved here remember when we do
impedance we are multiplying in by j and
rotating things by 90 degrees so we're
going to have different
different fee
for each one
and the other thing we're going to have
is we're going to have different
the amplitudes of our sinusoids are
going to be different the amplitude of
v1 it could be different than the
amplitude of v2
so this is what an ac solution is going
to look like let's let's move on a
little further here
what i'm going to do now is we're going
to take this input voltage plus these
things that we know here and we're going
to see how kirchhoff's voltage law works
in the frequency domain when we work
with these transformed
z's these impedances okay let's go ahead
and do that
okay let's do a little more in the time
domain
and we'll write out our kvl equation
again so the kvl equation was v naught
cosine
omega t plus v0
plus
v1 that's the amplitude of v1
cosine
omega t
plus some different phase angle
we don't know what that is yet
plus
v2 magnitude of v2
cosine
omega t plus
p3
plus
v3 amplitude of v3
cosine
omega t plus
phi 3
all equals zero
and omega all these omegas are the same
exact number the same radian frequency
all the fees are different and all the
v2s and v3s are different
okay now i'm going to switch
to complex exponential notation
we're just changing notation here we
could represent this number here as
this is the real part
of
v naught v zero e
to the j
times
omega t
plus
v
zero
that's exactly the same as this this
cosine can be represented as the real
part
of a complex exponential
with this frequency
and i can write out the rest of these
v1
e to the j
omega t plus v1
plus
the real part
of
v2
e to the j omega t
plus v2 parentheses
plus
v3
oops
real part
of
v3
e to the j
omega t plus
phi 3
equals
zero
all right now one thing i can do next we
can start to factor this we can start to
take this apart a little bit so i know
that if i have the expression
um if i had the expression e
to the j
omega
t
plus phi just in general i can change
that but just by exponent properties to
e to the j phi
oh let's get the parentheses in there
like that
e to the j phi times e to the j omega t
so i'm going to do this transformation
on all four of these terms here
let's keep going
so we're still working on this let's go
the real part now i'm going to take a
part omega t
and phi 0 here
and i get
v naught
e to the j
v 0
e to the j omega t
plus
real part
v 1
e to the j
phi 1
e to the j omega t
plus real
part
v 2
e to the j
times e to the j
omega t
plus real part
v3
e to the j v3
e to the j omega t
all equals zero
and here's a nice simplification
we take out this common term we're going
to factor out this common term
across the entire equation
and what do we come up with we come up
with
the result is the real part of
v zero
e to the j
p zero
plus
v one
e to the j
p one plus
v two
e to the j v2
see the pattern
all that
times
e to the j omega t
and we close that and that equals zero
and we're getting close we're getting
close
all right how do we make this equation
zero
does e to the j omega t ever become zero
well e to the j omega t
e to the j omega t is a rotating vector
it's never zero
so that's not going to do it so how do
we get it well that means that this
other term here has to be equal to 0.
so how am i going to do that let's uh
i'm going to make one more notational
change
this kind of a number here
is is
is called a
phaser
it's some amplitude times e to a complex
one angle
and there's no time up here there's no
time the time is only over here this is
the only place that time appears in the
equation and this is the only place that
omega appears in the equation and these
are just phase angles these are starting
phase angles so my notation for a phasor
is going to be
this is going to be called i'm going to
call it v 0 and i'm going to put a line
over it to indicate that it's a a
complex vector and that equals
v naught
e
to the j
phi naught
so when you see the vector symbol and
the ought
that's
that right there
and we can right now finally
the real part of
v naught
plus
v one
phasor plus v2
phasor plus v3 phasor
equals zero
so this is kvl
in the frequency domain
and fortunately it looks like it looks
exactly like kvl that we remember from
our dc analysis the sum of the voltages
going around the loop is equal to zero
and in this case it's the sum of the
phasors going around the loop is equal
to zero